what to do what to do what to do what to
do and become who Christopher Robin
there is something in the film about
this bit about Africa trilha quest when
you're trying to hire who in the
beginning your film is the dog no no you
could do that she does amazing dog
barking in the distance don't you know
that's not me but I'd like to know how
to do that
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what is it about the fact that this is
almost a hundred-year-old character that
people are still experienced
oh very nice thank you nice use of
experience I think he just still is
relevant you know it was so beautifully
written in its day by a Mel and
wonderfully realized by Disney through
the years and I just still think that
Pooh may be now even more than ever
before represents take you know making
us think about what's important and only
taking and time over things and taking
time just for times sake and more and
more we're on the go we're connected
we're you know we're social media were
making phone calls or answer emails from
the moment we wake up to the moment go
to sleep
there's no time just to sit and be this
can't be happening
stress it's not stress let's pool pool
how are you here oh well I went through
the door through which Christopher Robin
is known to appear and now I'm here the
tree I remember was behind the cottage
and the countryside not here in London I
suppose it's where it needs to be that's
a silly explanation what thank you the
truth is Christopher Robin change from
the last time you saw well as I recall
he's much taller than I remember
I've probably grown recognise me how
could anybody not recognise you how much
fun did you have making this movie well
I was allowed to do my own stunts and
sometimes even on purpose you're all
right how much fun did you have making
this movie it looks like a ton of fun
define fun
Tigger you have as much energy as I do
so just tell me in your most animated
voice what do you do this project well
it's like the row with written for me
I mean it's priced I know which is why I
never read the script why mess with
perfection don't be scared I won't hurt
you I just want to know what you're used
to the project oh well once boo said he
was doing it I said I'm in also well I
was too afraid to say no
[Music]
you must be Madeleine late he all the
bear of my father's drawings yes do you
know where he is I did I feel like
who'sa is a very simple character but he
has all this wisdom so I wanted to have
a storyline a story that's very simple
and really it's it's really reduced to
to this certain simplicity there's
nothing complicated it's truly about a
man who lost his his in a child doesn't
connect his family and has to find
himself again I always get to where I'm
going by walking away from where do you
turn
it's true movie magic and we were like I
was sitting there and seeking the Sun is
the right the clouds are right the light
is right
I have ewtn's and performance is on par
it's incredible he's connecting to air
every single take it was just I've ever
seen honestly it is extraordinary
yeah hello everyone how nice to see you
all again my thank you it's a little
bear
I was wrong about work I was wrong about
everything and I've got to get back to
my family
farewell Christopher Robin I wanted to
know when you guys probably everybody's
asking you what your character your most
like and I think we all have all these
characters in us first wake up in the
morning
are you like Tigger like yes I can do
this
are you like who like I don't do
anything but eat like are you like you
know I'm a definitely a cross between a
tiger and a poon okay I kind of bounced
out there but not with like necessarily
joy but there's more of a piglet sight
in your neurosis because too much to do
and I kind of jump out of bed I
definitely tweet I'm someone you can't
miss breakfast meet you yeah I'm the
same with coffee I just need to get up
make coffee yeah coffee yeah to get
coffee straight away sorry but uh yes
that's my honey coffee is my honey mmm
honey house clouds tree
dog poo what are you doing oh I'm
playing a game it's called say what you
see look could you say what you see a
little more quality
[Music]
oh no the great thing is about working
with poo we know he doesn't ask for
motivations he doesn't want a trailer
he's just like I tell him to go there he
does it just wait till the sequel by
change Oh before we keep going them you
wouldn't happen to have any honey would
you what's called say what you'll see in
fasting your disgrace and shame little
humiliation well that's one way to play
it
you